well i this this is the the news that
none of us wanted to
report or indeed to hear but you'll
remember in the first wave of
covert 19 part of the explanation for
why the uk had such a high death toll
was that
many care homes faced a high exposure to
covert 19 and you eventually had about
27 000
excess deaths in care homes getting on
for half of the total death toll
during this pandemic was in care homes
and the hope was that if there was going
to be a second wave then
at the very least we would be able to
protect care homes you wouldn't see a
big spike
in cases in care homes but i have got
hold of
some internal nhs data for
at least one pocket of the country which
shows that the story is
well worryingly familiar if anything
worse than in the spring it's for leads
and
these nhs data show and this space this
line shows you the number of cases
active cases within care homes in the
leeds area
and what you can see is it rose very
sharply in the first
wave of the pandemic around april may
june
and got up to about 150 160 or so
active cases in care homes and leads and
then came down
but just look at what's happened over
the course of the last it is literally
the last week and a bit
you've seen them rise incredibly sharply
from around 20 cases
up to over 200 so that now the number of
care home
cases of covert 19 that we have in this
area of the country and leeds
is actually higher than it was in the
spring so not only is there evidence of
spread to care homes and leads
like in many parts of the country we saw
a rise in cases of young people
of covert 19 but it's now looked like it
has spread in the community and has
spread into care homes but also just the
absolute level
is very high indeed a few provisos it
may well be that the level is
particularly high because we're doing
more testing there is more testing
happening in care homes
and also it's worth saying what we don't
know from these statistics is how many
of these cases
are residents versus the carers the
employees that work there and
i'm told that a chunk of them uh
potentially the majority are people who
work there but we don't have that
breakdown what we do have is this and
there's unpublished
nhs data and it is very alarming indeed
because as i say the hope was
that care homes would be protected
protected in the second wave the hope
was that you wouldn't see
covert spread from the community into
these care homes where there are many
elderly many vulnerable people
but unfortunately now we know for the
first time that in at least one part of
the uk
that spread is happening and the rise of
cases is very worrying indeed